how are you nice to have you here oh
it's great to be here yeah nice new
studio this is new this is a new
experience yes yeah it's quite a giant
moon big fake moon behind you actually
the studio was easy to find than the
channel on the tv
but i persevered yeah you really it
takes a while i didn't know that there
were that many channels to be honest
until we came to this channel i didn't
realize and i'll be honest with you i
sometimes forget where we are in los
angeles yeah
what is what are we on here i have no
idea
i always get stuck on the costume
jewelry and then i just i went you know
you go through that you keep going you
go to costume jewelry um eyebrow
plucking channel and you know and then
eventually you find osama bin laden's
got a chat show just before yours
[Laughter]
it's very good
he's killing us with the bookings uh
now uh tell me let's talk about uh your
gig that's coming up the golden globes
uh people love it when you host this
show very good at it there was a
perception a little bit last year that
you you were very good but you didn't go
for the jugular oh that's one thing i i
think i in retrospect i think i held
back a little bit you know i didn't want
to i didn't want to offend anyone but i
didn't want to be totally at wow
she loved it yeah
one out of 200 people always will yeah
but you know i just i want to do i want
to do a proper job the thing is i
haven't run anything by them the good
thing about it is they don't want to see
anything they said that last year i
don't show them the script and um i had
to tell them about one thing i wanted to
do because i knew it was a bit of a
stunt and i needed their cooperation i
needed a costume and i told him and i
said no we can't do that so i'm going to
chuck you down
can you tell us what that idea was so we
we know yeah it wasn't that yeah um
maybe we could well no maybe we could
use it
oh and it'll be the the opening you know
ricky please welcome ricky gervais i was
going to come out dressed as adolf
hitler right
no right right and i was going to come
out with almost just doing that wave
into the right and then get to the
podium and let it die down and go
too much
right
and then i want to look in the crowd and
go it's the wrong crowd it's just the
wrong crowd and then i was going to say
that's the last time i borrow a suit
from mel gibson
[Applause]
i think i think now we're just worried
about maybe the picture in the paper the
next year
with their logo the network logo right
there
nbc more colorful uh
no we don't want that
now you have an upcoming hbo special i
want to mention talking funny and this
is where uh it sounds fascinating you
talk
comedy with comedians yeah i just don't
know
you know i i love just you know chatting
that the the uh the ricky gervais show
started off with a podcast with just two
mates just chatting i just love that i
just think that you can go anywhere with
it i'd like to do one um you know with
show runners you know
with talk show hosts yeah yeah yeah talk
show host yeah i was thinking i'm just
uh just the crew me leno obviously
brilliant um
david letterman yeah king yeah and jon
stewart
and then anyone else i mean there could
be you can maybe we could do i mean
there's a lot of cha cha so we could do
two maybe um oh oh who else is there i'm
craig ferguson he's great jimmy jimmy
fallon right right and now what if you
expanded it and got even more people in
there you could probably larry larry
sanders is fictional so
i'm i'm running
come on
george lopez
i could come out at some point and just
bring you all tea and then yeah you
could dismiss me run along i start to
talk no no not a word out you go
out to go your chimney sweep is that an
english accent yes hello governor
brilliant
thank you thank you
[Applause]
are you gonna pick me pocket
could i have more porridge please this
is you know you could please have some
more poor tricky could i just say one
thing you know you know this is a
breakdown don't you yes
i'm having a horrible breakdown it's
just christ please let's go to
commercial
i need to take a lot of medication right
away
you've had a year off yeah and this is
how you
yes
wow i had a lot i went through a lot
i've had treated i've been treated with
all kinds of chemicals your job last
year was growing a beard
right
do you like me beard hey ricky okay this
is mental he's got he's absolutely lost
it